you got two seats at portillo's michelle
obama
jordan and oprah who you eating with ah
i'm dropping jordan man
no portillo's for jordan
[Music]
we're here at longalois state where i
found out that wine wasn't just
something i wanted to share with my
family
was something i wanted to share with the
world it's here that we created chosen
family wines
[Music]
well guys we have a amazing amazing day
in store for you
some drinking some wine talking hoops
with the wnba champion
a two-time ncaa champion defensive
player of the year
five-time all-star five-time russian
league champion
four-time russian cup one-time euro
league champion
and i mean if we can look at all these
accolades we would have to do this all
day
i just want to say thanks to candace
nicole parker for being here
all full-bodied as the wines get darker
the questions are going to get deeper
first of all we have to pop open this
champagne
i knew you were good i did not know
you were all god level good that's
cheers to you
and everything that you've accomplished
what i've seen over the last few years
not only from what you have done from
what a lot of other powerful women have
done in the nba and around sports is
change the culture of how we see women
in the workplace
how we see women as mothers um and as
professionals
and overall you just cool the [ __ ] so
you know cheers to you
[Music]
i think the first thing that i want to
talk about is 2016.
2016. man um
it's interesting that you're talking
about uh
champagne at this point in time because
i remember
i got some dom perio in 2008
that was given to me after we won the
ncaa championship
and they handed it to me and i decided i
wasn't going to open it
until we won a wba championship okay
you know in 2008 so this is back in 2008
i'm thinking like yo
you know maybe one maybe two years you
know maybe three
maybe four ended up being a whole lot
longer
than one maybe two years here's
something that
i didn't know you played the end of your
rookie season
pregnant how in god's green earth
did you play at an elite level not only
taking care of yourself
but obviously taking care of your your
healthy amazing wonderful daughter at
the same time
honestly um i thought i was just
tired you know i had played a year
straight i had played ever since the
year before with usa basketball and then
played all of college and then went
straight to wnba season and then from
wba season i went to the olympics and
then back to wba
and after the olympics which is when i
was pregnant with my daughter
i just thought i was tired so we pushed
through that season and um
you know it didn't end the way that we
wanted to on the court in terms of we
lost in the western conference final on
a last second shot but that's for
another drink
listen we got sips at the same time you
know winning rookie of the year in mvp
i wasn't really thinking about that
right it was i was disappointed at the
end of the year and then i got this
amazing surprise
so anybody that knows me i've always
wanted to be a mom and honestly it
couldn't have come at a better time it
was at the early stage of my career
where
now my daughter and i have grown up
together i don't remember basketball
before her
i mean if you think about it it wasn't
being pregnant playing it was coming
back after pregnancy to me
that was hard right she was six weeks
old
when i came back and stepped up out on
the court and played for the first time
my wife got pregnant it took me six
months to get back to the court
i think that needs to get talked about
more about how powerful that
is that you guys are not just sitting on
the side and not that that's wrong but
you guys are still continuing
to play the sport that is so hard that
it's so physical that it's so daunting
at an elite level and also
growing another amazing human being
inside you cheers thank you channy
to completely throw this off since i've
given you 10 minutes of compliments
you got two seats at portillo's michelle
obama
jordan and oprah who you eating with ah
i'm dropping jordan man
i'm dropping george no portillo's for
jordan no
i think honestly jordan and michelle
obama would both give up their seat
if i picked either one of them over
oprah so i think that's it
on this next wine this was new to me in
the last few years
so this is chablis what i know from
white wine
is the old school big buttery oaky
you just take wet butter popcorn right
that's what my parents grew up on
that was my image of chardonnay but we
picked this for you
because chablis was made from the exact
same grape 100 chardonnay
but instead of months and oak it's made
in steel vats
it's in a different environment it still
has a legendary classic taste
on the same note without you leaving la
to go to chicago we would never get to
witness your next step
the evolution this chablis so i wanted
to share this with you and let you know
how excited i am
of your future thank you i'm gonna open
mine though so as you're opening that
i think i've been around more chicago
people
than any other city in the world because
i played for zeke
played with quentin richardson played
with eddie curry
right but what is it like to be from
chicago
well first i want to i want to say
because i've gotten a lot of flack
lately
where i don't claim to be from chicago i
claim to be from chicagoland
and i make this very clear oh that's
good that i am from the serb
suburbs proud to be from naperville
suburban commando graduated high school
from naperville central
but i graduated on the court from the
chicagoland area i played near
far downtown western suburbs you talk
about north
south everywhere in the state of
illinois you know it's just a different
breed
of people and when you're
playing basketball just it's a different
following
i know some of it is home but it's just
all about support and following there's
so many people that i run into
that are from naperville or from the
chicagoland area that have followed me
my entire career
right and to say that that hasn't been a
part of my journey
no it just was only right to go back
home so
i do believe in full circle and things
like that but i think it was just kind
of like the right time
you know to go back to what i'm used to
and go back to where i'm from to end
because you know channing the end is
near it's coming
listen the end ain't too bad girl you
can do these shows with me it's coming
i'm ready to do this more on the regular
if i think about all the chicago players
that have come out
number one is a loyalty to that city
and a loyalty to pass on like the
tradition of griminess
every chicago player is willing to
number one throw hands
and number two elbow you if it costs
winning the game
right i think it's a little bit of
everything because you know
i think illinois as a whole has a style
and a brand of basketball
for me personally i think i'm fluid i
mean you said
throw hands i'll definitely do that but
at the same time i've seen you elbow
many of people
oh don't tell them about all those times
on set shanny nah
um but the versatility i think is a big
part
just being effective but i don't want it
to to get confused like we're extremely
skilled
um versatile fluid yeah oh yeah but i
i would take r5 any day oh for sure
you are one of the first women adidas
athletes there's not been a lot of
women's signature shoes do you think
that's gonna start coming around and
how can that like culture change where
you know my little
my daughter can get her first candace
parkers well here's the first and
foremost uh
channing i've been fortunate enough to
be with partnerships for a long time
it's really important to me to do
something authentic
and loyalty is huge to me honestly
and that's why it was so difficult for
me to leave the sparks
because usually when i start something
i've always been taught to finish
and i did my contract was up so i was
able to go but the same with adidas
i have been three stripes basically
since my junior year
in high school i've been in adidas since
the first kobe's
that came out the the moon boots oh the
moon joints
i've been in adidas that long it's
always been a part of
what i'm doing and i've always had a
strong relationship with them
so when i got out of college after being
four years of adidas at tennessee at the
time tennessee was adidas it was a
no-brainer to be honest with you
it is important for me to make a shoe
that's a signature and represented by a
woman
but at the same time i've gone into
adidas and carved out this
niche for all genders like i want i want
little boys to be
okay with wearing my shoes
and so that's been a huge effort for me
are they gonna have some some tight
color ways or what
we got you channing we're we're it's in
the works oh good
and a lot of it was sizing issues too
like making things gender-neutral right
right right
but making them in men's sizes and there
had been no
up into this point there had been women
that had signature shoes you talk about
lisa leslie cheryl swoops
but there hadn't been women that had had
signature shoes in men's sizes
and so that was important to me was to
make more of a gender neutral
so that we introduce the fact that it is
okay
to then dream about you know wearing
different shoes and different
collections similar to like you're
seeing beyonce you're seeing a lot of
men that are rocking
ivy park okay and so i think it's
similar to like that kind of thing where
it's okay to look up to women and see
women in leadership positions and i
think it starts with
shoe companies and organizations and
your partnerships uh putting women out
there like that
speaking of that because you you held my
transitions better than i could
we're gonna go to this third one so
stagsleep wine cellars are known for
their napa cabs
that's pretty much all i drink our napa
cabs
gotten into a little bit of the french
wine burgundies
burgundies yes i have a lot of friends
that are french and so they're getting
me into their wine
i've kind of been heavy into wine
probably the last four years
i would say i have to admit i was
in my 20s and not to throw shade i'm not
throwing shade at any wine but i was
more of the sweet moscato
in the shopping aisle like give me the
cupcake uh-oh you know the sweetest wine
the little kangaroo huh i was one of
those in my 20s
and when i hit about 28 29 years old
i had a really good friend that really
got heavy into wine
yeah and i'm very coachable so
show me what you like and tell me about
it
i'm gonna research it i'm gonna do all
that stuff and in santa barbara's right
up the road
napa is not too far so i just started
taking trips and and going to
vineyards and wineries and i've really
fallen in love and like you said
the question i used to ask when i was
early on was what's your favorite wine
yeah but really it depends like you said
it could be a 10
bottle and it's shared over a dinner
that's memorable and so honestly i
started keeping
like important yeah you're ed you got
the bug
so i got i got the bug but i got um
i got some important corks in here of
like nights and i write on them
dude that's the best business deals
times you know i got a 2016 cork in here
where
that was when we won the championship
that's tight i really kind of taken to
it
one last last last last thing
okay this is a fun game it's called fill
in the green
do you want to play the game or do you
want to say whatever you want to say i
want to play the game
and i want to say whatever i'm going to
say oh i want more
boss there's five categories the lady
balls
slam dunk contest your 2016 chip
music and kicks we're gonna go through
each category in whatever order you want
if you can't get it right you got to
take a sip all right okay
which one do you want to go first i'll
do kicks what shoe did you have on when
you became the second player in wmd nba
history
to dunk in a game i remember the shoes
they were the
adidas like with the little strap with
the strap on them
the adidas with the strap on them were
they the ace commanders
no i'm gonna just drink because i want a
drink cause it's good the adidas
piranha 3.0 yeah i didn't get that
i'll go music what was jay-z's number
one
selling album of all time volume two
hard knock life
or volume three life and times of s
carter
hard knock life oh correct i guess i'll
drink because that is right
i'll drink with you channing thank you
so slam dunk contest
what was your final slam dunk score
after the first round
i know i got like one nine i think but
i'm gonna just drink because i don't oh
i don't know the score 145
okay so i got a couple nines lady bulls
here we go
can you name the six lady bulls who have
their basketball jerseys retired
deidre charles myself holly warlick
tamika catchings shamiq holsclaw
and bg is the initials
bridgette gordon how could i forget her
here we go i know bridget gordon
okay but i'll drink for that cause i got
it wrong last question 2016 how many
rebounds did you
and nika each have in game five of your
2016 championship
12. oh i can't remember how many points
i had in my last game and that was only
two years ago
man 2016. that's a that's a memory yeah
i'll say this i'm going back to
champaign 2016 got your boy having a
hangover already
thank you so much for coming anything
else you want to say
you have the most interesting life which
is shocking because i thought you were
very boring but
you are amazing
well channing first and foremost i want
to say thank you so much
you know i love that we're expanding as
to what athletes are
and considered to be i love that you're
you're doing this
getting into wine i realize like you
said not everything is the most
expensive
bottle it doesn't have to be i do have
expensive taste so some of those are you
know i like staglin i like colgan
i like stagland i had a screaming eagle
a couple
a couple weeks ago for a friend's
birthday oh that was probably the most
expensive bottle i've ever had in my
life
you got that money money no i didn't pay
for it let's go back home do they have
state taxes
trust me i ain't paid for it okay okay
3.99 right up my alley
keep the corks write down goals or write
down
memories write down who was at the
dinner because it's really a cool
keepsake that i've started
and you know i hope at some point to
share a bottle in person
with you you bring your favorite i bring
my favorite and we'll we'll get this
thing going
listen i'll just bring my wine sounds
amazing awesome thank you so much
thank you channing let's finish this
though you're a savage